[Applause]
hey
oh hey hello
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith
i'm mark bernhardt hey
[Applause]
hey uh here we are doing a home show
ladies and gentlemen i don't know
if you realize this but normally of
course we're in the scum and villainy
cantina and they're here in hollywood
boulevard
in hollywood but hollywood is uh been
what do they call it mark it's not a
lockdown what is it it's a it's a
general stay-at-home order encouraging
you to stay at home
yeah strongly encouraging it's like you
know [ __ ] dick hair away from a
lockdown so
everything has been changing curfew
there's there's all of it
you can't go to a restaurant inside or
outside
at this point only pick up so
in the spirit of adhering to the rules
we don't want to break the rules and
[ __ ] we don't want to
joe in the scum and villainy cantina
have the [ __ ]
covered cops bust in with enough
[ __ ] man we don't need to add to his
troubles so
we're doing a home show um and uh
but it ain't that doesn't mean it's a
lesser show by any stretch of the
imagination
have we got content for you kids
we got to uh before we'll be you know
we're gonna be talking about
going uh uh ahsoka
to mouth like crazy we're gonna be
talking about the mandalorian
um we're gonna talk about this that's
gonna be amazing
uh we're gonna talk about all the news
that mark's collected for us but before
we do
anything we got to talk about the people
who are
paying for tonight's show the good folks
at manscape look at them mark got it
right there now
mark manscaped for those uh who are just
tuning in
you get 20 off and free shipping
at manscaped.com
with the code fatman20
yes atm and 20. uh be the ballsiest gift
giver this year
with manscape so make sure you go over
to manscape.com even as we're talking
about this but
point point of fact we've been talking
about manscape for weeks on our show
they're lovely people they got a hell of
a [ __ ] product
man it's meant for ball shaven but i'll
be honest with you
it's dick tickling as well if held the
right way
um but mark had said time and time again
that he uses it to shave his head i do
we have the luxury of this home show i
was like hey man
show your [ __ ] clippers so they know
we're for real this ain't
no hustle it's not us going like use
manscaped and we're
over there using some other product and
[ __ ]
look at this man
that's ladies that's the sound of
pleasure right there
it's like a lightsaber and it does it's
actually creating a pretty nice light
effect
turn off your your [ __ ] vanity ring
light
now turn around oh look at that [ __ ]
industrial light magic can't do better
than that nope
look right here i'll neutralize you
i forgot what we were talking about the
only thing i remember is that
manscape.com
is waiting for you right now man what do
they got they're doing
stock and stuffers ladies and gentlemen
oh yes looks for the
ultimate stock and stuffers for this
holiday season well
look no further kids look no further
because our sponsors manscape
have the tools to make you win this
year's stock and stuffer
or white elephant competition or yankee
swap whatever they're called
manscaped is the only brand dedicated to
below the waist grooming
and hygiene products man they got ball
lotions for heaven's sake
great news they just released their
products all across
europe so if you've been in europe
watching this show going
when can i get my hands on some of that
sweet manscape ball product
now is the time not only europe but
canada
and australia manscape taking over the
world you know why
because there are mans everywhere and
they all got balls
and all those balls need tending to this
is a smart product you know i always
tell you to say to myself mark
if i go back in time i would have taken
whatever money i made for clerks and
mall rats
i would have invested in storage units
because [ __ ]
they're everywhere oh my god i would be
a billionaire by now
but i would also now go back in time and
invest in in [ __ ] manscapes because
it's a no-brainer
half the population of the entire planet
has balls that need tendon to you know
and not for nothing
a hundred percent of the population has
pubic hair
i mean we call it manscaped but i bet
you the ladies could use it too
hell yeah with that vibrating effect
might be
not getting in ladies a few of their
products
that are prime stocking stuffers this
season are
the crop preserver ball deodorant name
speaks for itself but i'll say a little
bit more about it
ball deodorant this is a genius idea
whose time has [ __ ] come man
who wants to smell sweaty balls all the
time throw some [ __ ] deodorant on
that [ __ ] man good idea
i appreciate a brand that puns as well
as manscape does
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver ball toner
spray on toner that will give your balls
a nice little slice of heaven with their
aloe vera and hazel extract crop
cleanser what is a toner by the way
that's just it's a something you put on
like a i mean i think it keeps the skin
nice and tight
because you know especially on them
balls like them balls you don't
necessarily want a bag of raisins you
want to you want a
like nice smooth carrying case for your
hard-boiled eggs of nuts
[ __ ] you better turn your vanity ring
light off
that [ __ ] all sexy i'll do declare
butler tell me about your crop mop oh
uh the crop cleanser body wash a full
body wash
that you can also use on your hair not
just your ball hair
your head hair uh crop mop ball wipes
you never know when an opportunity
strikes so you should always be prepared
i gotta get me some of those
foot duster foot deodorant i could
really use this my foot stank
uh designed to keep the stankiest feet
smelling fresh man
when it comes to the shears 2.0 is a
luxury four-piece nail kit as well
the weave whacker nose ear and hair
trimmer which provides
proprietary uh skin safe technology get
rid of those
nasty nose hair let's not forget about
the best trimmer for your butt balls and
body
which i believe mark was holding up
right there
the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer offers a
replaceable ceramic blade with advanced
skin safe technology
which helps reduce grooming accidents
but get this these formulations
are all vegan so i'm on board they're
all cruelty free
dye free sulfate free paraben free
and shame free lazy gem it's time to
embrace the balls
they ain't going anywhere so let's start
taking care of them am i right mark
um unless you get caught in a horrible
motorcycle accident
in which case you slide up on a gas cap
and you might lose a ball but you're not
going to lose the hair
that's true man good he's talking real
that's some real talk right there facts
real ball talk you know what else are
facts you get 20
off plus free shipping at manscape.com
right now if you use the code fat man 20
all one big big ass word uh whether this
is for your partner
your dad your brother your friend or as
mark pointed out this works on ladies
too
uh getting something that they will
actually use and it's
almost sure to get a laugh you know how
you get people
joke gifts and [ __ ] like that and it's
like uh oh thanks i won't use this but
thanks
they would [ __ ] use this and if not
they could re-gift it to somebody and
get a
bigger [ __ ] reaction as you got from
it
if you get a crop preserver in your
stocking you'll give it a little chuckle
but you'll be feeling pretty good down
below you actually use it too first
you'll laugh be like ah so funny and
then later on one day you'll be like
yanking him up yeah sure not [ __ ]
like a russian bonus crops
that's a long week ago get 20 off and
free shipping
at manscaped.com ladies and gentlemen
with the code fatman20
be the ballsiest gift giver this year
with manscaped all right
thank you to the good folks at [ __ ]
manscapes man indeed
um apparently we're selling some [ __ ]
ball shavers man i love our hairy group
either that or they're just like look
it's not working but we believe in you
boys so
maybe one day someone will buy some one
of these days you're gonna
your lucky number's gonna come up um
okay
two things i wanna talk about in our
upfront before we get to
blowing the mandalorian all right bring
it uh
number one um uh
there's a project that um
a friend of mine nate quarry is doing
called
uh zombie cage fighter
um i've loved this at one point i tried
to turn it into a show man cause i was
like in a world where they're doing
the you know the [ __ ] walking dead
how can this not be a [ __ ] show
um it's about a cage fighter who is
forced to um you know
[ __ ] uh fight on behalf of his
daughter
and who he fights is they put him in the
cage with [ __ ] zombies takes place in
a post-apocalyptic world man
right you know what i'm saying that's a
[ __ ] no-brainer idea when he told me
that
nate was he was on uh comic book men
back in the day
but to me this was like such a
no-brainer idea i was like that's so
[ __ ] good man
so he's got a kickstarter um
that he asked me to shout out and i'm
happy to shout it out go to kickstarter
right now
zombie cage fighter you can watch like
the whole selection for it and stuff
like that
um but it's uh he sent me a copy of the
graphic novel it's not here it's in my
bedroom
in my shelvings i should have thought to
bring it here and stuff
um i i dig this project man
i i i i 100 believe in it he's doing
this
uh graphic novel a collection of the
completed six
issue comic book series so the book's
done
um what it was it says pledged 55
75 of a 5 000 go so it looks like he had
his [ __ ] goal already but
go support it man go buy this [ __ ]
book it is legit wonderful idea
and it's only a matter of time before
somebody smart figures out this should
be a [ __ ] tv show
okay um that's for nate and that's for
zombie cage fighter uh speaking of comic
books
and i've seen books uh they're
beautiful this i'm gonna read you the
copy this ain't an ad they didn't pay
for this or anything like this but they
sent me this book
and it is i can't wait to share it man
this is called the marvel made
paragon collection
you could go to if you want to follow
along if you're watching at home
open a side window and go to marvel
marvelmademade.net
for this thing i'm going to show you
which apparently you could pre-order
um and it's available through december
4th
uh i'm not going to lie to you this is
the same for the fainthearted
it's a 199 bucks but when i show it to
you
if this is remotely into your s in on
your radar and
in a world where fat man uh beyond
caters to
the culture of pop and comic books in
particular this will be on a lot of
folks radar if you're looking for the
perfect christmas gift for somebody
this might be it man it's starting now
through december 4th
the marvel made paragon collection the
chris
claremont premiere bundle it's going to
be available
pre-order on marvelmade.net only
produced
though this is the catch if they get
1200 pre-orders
or more otherwise they don't make the
[ __ ] book
but they're they make the book and it's
it has a hand numbered
and individually signed copy it's part
of a hand numbered individually signed
series stunning high-end books and
lithographs
and like all marvel made products each
this sounds like an ad but they sent me
the copy
each collection will be released for a
limited time
only um so let now that i've told you
what it is
and what it costs and where you can go
look along people could probably
you know follow along online let me hold
it up so you can [ __ ] see this [ __ ]
they sent me a prototype because they
were like hey man
might this be something you'd mention on
your show and i'm like [ __ ]
yes that is very relevant to our
interests do uh
do i want to know more yes this
is the book now this is fine let me get
in close on that
geez i would need bigger shelves
i mean [ __ ] dude they need to do this
for everything
um okay this is what the back of it
looks like and it says
marvel made um
this is the chris claremont uh
paragon collection so it looks like a
thick-ass book
now watch when i open it oh
oh it's a smaller aztec book that's
right it's
the russian nesting doll of the book so
books this is just a gigantic gorgeous
container and the book's inside i'm
gonna put it over here
or i could put it here and then lift up
the book
okay here comes the book that's inside
and i'll pull this thing out cause i'm
gonna get to that as well
this is the gorgeous [ __ ] book that's
inside it looks exactly like the
oversized case
but inside the book
you get one at ease certificate of
authenticity
and it's signed by uh cb sablusky and
and uh
uh and chris claremont himself
um this
this is nuts okay
it's numbered
down below as like one of two thousand
this [ __ ] is handwritten dude and they
ain't written to kevin smith they're
writing this in each copy of the book
it looks like chris claremont wrote
welcome to the x-men hope you survived
the experience which is a quote
so hand drawn first page hand written
and then inside you get x-men 94
x-men 129 through 137
x-men 141 and uncanny x-men 142
wolverine one through four
uncanny x-men 268
uncanny x-men 140.5
x-men number one um
and i think that's the contents of the
book um you get
an intro by louise simonsen gold leaf
pages
and then gorgeous reproductions
of some of the most important marvel
books
ever published can you see that yeah
holy crap
it is [ __ ] gorgeous
now you know dc does the absolute
editions
this seems like that souped up this
seems like
that you know put through the marvel
method and [ __ ]
it is it's stunning dude
stunning if i knew somebody like
i do know somebody you know who would
love to [ __ ] out of this
walter flanagan there you go comics no
more but he loves the classic [ __ ]
and he loves the presentational books
like the books that
the marvel master works here
this is like marvel masterworks you know
[ __ ] pumped up to look like
kingpin and it's a collection of stuff
that claremont
worked on and then also in the back
you've got scripts
so you can read the actual scripts and
he's got a sequel a prelude
to a future past a new piece
oh wow that is awesome i guess it's with
who is it uh
larocca so they did a prelude to days of
future
past so it's a brand new story in the
back of this [ __ ] book
um what else is here and then it looks
like there's some people writing about
the issues um like breakdowns
i get and it looks like the claremont
commentary
chris claremont shares his thoughts on
the stories collected in this volume
in conversation with jess harold
so it's packed if you're a claremont
x-men
fan or just claremont fan but if you're
a claremont fan you're probably a
claremont x-man fan
this is absolutely a must-have it also
comes with
the marvel made edition bagged and
boarded comic
of days of future past
and then it also comes with this which
is uh
x-men 13 uncanny x-men and it has this
cover
bagged and boarded inside and then
it also has the uh what looks like i'm
assuming art
cards yes so there's
oh look at that there's a [ __ ]
casada wolverine
that's badass yeah joe's an amazing
artist as we all know
um this is a salvador
la roca piece let me get in closer
[Music]
nice this is
a i can't quite see
um phil no two-piece
oh yeah phil mito girl
and this is another phil no two piece
and this is gorgeous it's like the full
cast of the
x universe so it comes with four of
these
art plates suitable for framing as they
say
um i this is stunning
i'm delighted they sent it to me uh
it'll look [ __ ] wonderful in my house
uh it should look in yours as i said if
you go to marvelmaid.net now you could
pre-order this book
the whole bundle is 199 bucks
um pre-order is available through
december 4th
and unless they get 1200 orders they
don't
order them they don't make it so if you
order by december 12th
uh sorry fourth do you know if they they
will guarantee you christmas shipping
you got to imagine no my bad there's
information here
uh bundles will begin shipping march
2021
excellent [ __ ] ad mark you know some
people be like
you can order it and you can give
somebody a card this is what you're
getting but they're not gonna
right they're gonna be able to open that
[ __ ] wait till the ides of march friend
marvel won't be officially announcing
this part until tomorrow
but they are giving our watchers our
viewers
an early heads up that a new wolverine
comic is being added to the premiere
bundle
it's an exclusive comic by chris
claremont
that directly ties into the original
iconic 1982 wolverine limited series
that he did with frank miller and this
comic will have a cover
by steve mcniven so they just sweetened
the world they threw in another comic
book as well that's not represented
in what i just showed here if you got a
marvel fan in your life a marvel comic
book fan
uh if you're an x-men person if you love
those movies and don't know
much about the source material uh if
you're a comic book enthusiast
if you're a book lover who likes classy
collections
i can't i can't uh [ __ ]
recommend this enough it is [ __ ]
gorgeous i only hope
that the good folks that marvel made do
a [ __ ] daredevil
a guardian angel a guardian devil
edition man that
[ __ ] night i'll give them anything
they want i'll give them nudes
if that's what they want this is
gorgeous so that's what i got about that
you got any
opening [ __ ] you want to talk about my
friend uh what did i do
this past week you know thanksgiving so
i ate
uh gave thanks uh did not see any family
aside from my immediates
um other than on the zooms way to keep
it [ __ ]
pure man indeed yeah you know had i had
a couple of family zooms which is nice
i had a birthday yesterday that's right
martin hardy's birthday was yesterday
ladies and gentlemen how old did you
turn
i turned 49. i'm an old look at it all
man
what would you do for your birthday um
you know
similar to thanksgiving not very much at
all i kind of i ate like a champ
just busted the diet wide open for some
barbecue
i went for a little hike um up by by
where i am place called garden of the
gods up in chatsworth
if uh if you if you like the feel of
spawn movie ranch
from uh once upon a time in hollywood
this is about where that is
um and it's all these old rock
formations they used to use in in
westerns back in the day
um so that was a cute little hike um
yeah you know and and again saw some
family saw some friends
on virtual connections only um
you know and and saw that that marvel
had released a very sweet little thing
because i happen to share a birthday
with chadwick boseman we are both born
on the 29th
it was his birthday i saw on online
yesterday
yeah so weird uh yeah and marvel you
know for
in tribute of the late chadwick boseman
they
refashioned the marvel studios logo in
front of black panther and disney plus
so that all the faces that you normally
see hey there's a hulk and black widow
and cap or whatever
it's all chadwick and it's all black
yeah the chadwick boseman version of the
stan lee
correct memorial they did at the top of
either captain marvel or one of the
avengers movies yeah it might have been
might have been the top of end game
um but yeah that that that felt
very sweet and very touching uh not for
my birthday i mean it's cool and thank
you marvel for thinking of me
but i know it wasn't i'm saying it's for
your birthday they know how [ __ ]
powerful you all are in this movie
like we gotta locate the school we gotta
do something special versus 49
let's start trash talking our movies and
we can't [ __ ] tell them anymore
um yeah that was really [ __ ] sweet of
them
uh to do and and uh the flexibility
to do that only in a digital streaming
age
saying unless you were due like we
re-released the movie and we put a new
logo at the front
but you know since you own disney plus
you can do whatever you want with it and
stuff yeah absolutely that's great man
that's sweet so yeah and you know
watched watch some television i finished
ted lasso i don't know if we had talked
about me finishing it
um the last time which i loved love to
death if you haven't seen
amanda if you haven't seen ted lasso yet
you are missing
the the shiny perfect emotional nougati
diamond of the quarantine
um it is an incredibly um sweet show
it is it is unironically um
buoyant um and it's about a sport that i
don't particularly care that much about
i'm not i'm not a
football fan i'm not a soccer fan um
but it it it functions the same way as
that queen's gambit does with chess
it is not about the chess it's about the
people who play the chess and this one
is about the people play the game and
it's
it's so lovely so glad that i finished
that up um
what's up funny it is very funny
um there there is no two ways about it
like two or three
knock down drag out laugh lines um
jokes that land incredibly hard um but
yeah i think
dude you're in the normal show like my
hands were so [ __ ] dry
because the marvel the marvel paragon
edition sucked all the real juice out of
it
all that paper pulled all the bug
moisture yeah i started watching a show
called wayne
um i've watched a trailer for this it's
on it
or something yeah yeah it used to be it
used to be one of the youtube premiums
it was part of the
the the cobra kai class um
and uh and the guy who ran um or may
still be running the continental fella
named sean simmons
this was his show um sort of set in and
around brockton massachusetts where he
grew
up um and it's a friend of mine
a friend of mine described it as like
high school conan the barbarian
um and it was the perfect description
for it
um it it similarly is winning in in some
of the ways that ted lasso is and that
you have this main character who
um just believes in doing the right
thing
under the worst circumstances and never
lies
and always says always does what he says
he's going to do
kind of a leslie knope if you will a
little bit of a leslie knope
but also who punches people a lot like
it's crazily hyper violent
um in a in a sort of lovely almost
endearing way like what if john hughes
really liked manslaughter um
i mean wayne wayne and now it's on
amazon prime
what's what where does it take place
it's really yeah brockton mass
i remember watching the trailer and the
kid had a thick [ __ ] accent
yeah um so yeah i i i told sean that i
would never watch a show
while i was working for him and now i'm
not and so i did
good recco man i'm gonna check that out
i watched i don't know if i talked about
it last week but have you watched moon
base eight on showtime yet i have not
adorable yeah yeah funny um if
armistan's great
[ __ ] john c reilly's great tim
heidecker is great
really fun [ __ ] show and i remember
when i you know
they announced space force for netflix
and then
this guy i saw a billboard for this or i
read an announcement for this and i was
like
i mean why would you bother completely
[ __ ] different
its own very unique thing um
like i they must have shot it during
quarantine because
it's very minimal it's just the three of
them and stuff smart
legit [ __ ] funny man like there's
some [ __ ]
made me cry i'll let john john seaman
again is it no johnson riley john c
reilly goes uh
at one point he's like under the weather
and they're trying to quarantine him and
[ __ ]
and he's like i need i need lemons i
need
piping hot lemons piping hot lemons had
me laughing for like
a really good show only like eight
episodes
nice like half an hour right even less
so he's easy like you're done in three
hours or something or four hours
totally worth watching uh the undoing
finished last night did you watch that
at all on h
i did i watched all of it and i watched
the finale
yeah what
without spoiling it without spoiling it
or you know advanced
word like if you if you're looking
forward to watching the undoing or you
haven't watched the end of the undoing
maybe you know [ __ ] put us on mute
for a second and when i go like this
like dirk dirk that means uh you can
take the mute back off all right and
what was the feeling on the ending i i
you know i'm like well
it's got to be the kid no it's going to
be her friend the lady who's in it
and she's kind of famous but like they
didn't focus on her enough she's got to
be there for a reason
or wait it's going to be nicole herself
when she he [ __ ] blurts it out on the
stand or
maybe it's the kid like the victim's kid
like [ __ ]
and then they did what they did
they did it uh did you watch the the
outsider do you remember that the jason
bateman
you know which which has a very similar
premise right which is like
beloved family man um who you know
held in reverence by the town or
whatever um
seems to have done an unspeakable thing
um you know jason bateman plays a guy
who apparently also killed you know and
sexually assaulted like four children
um and the bodies were found in the
woods and so he gets arrested
always maintaining his innocence but all
the evidence was like dude you did it we
found your
dna and your hair follicles and
everything and
then there's a twist and it's a giant
twist and i mean granted this thing is
now almost a year old
maybe i don't know time but uh there's
like a doppelganger some like mystical
force that you know can replicate people
and goes from town to town
feeding on children pretending to be
adults who trust them
and it's like oh all right not at all
what i thought it was going to be
excellent let's follow this the undoing
turns out to have been kind of exactly
what it said it was going to be from the
jump
which is hey here's the guy who uh did
it here's all the evidence that he did
it
um he says he didn't do it but you know
what happened he did it
that i couldn't [ __ ] believe it i'm
like i was so busy looking for every
twist and turn
and instead they went with the real
version which
is like of course the husband did it
like it's always the [ __ ] husband
isn't it and so
jennifer who i watched it with she was
satisfied she was like i liked it she's
going although we were looking for all
these
twists she's gone you know they played
it real of course he did it like he's an
animal
right i i was like it's gotta be the boy
you know like it's gotta be one of the
two boys
um maybe the husband uh the act you know
the husband of the girl who got killed
right anyone but the most obvious person
which
leads me to believe i would be a
terrible cop
i wouldn't look at the most obvious i'd
be like you know who we should look at
[ __ ] the mayor and they're like the
mayor like
i mean it's outside the box like i
i didn't see that coming i guess because
i was looking for too many different
twists and turns
i can't say i was dissatisfied
like when it ended i wasn't like what
the [ __ ]
but i was shocked in 2020
that david e kelly let it just be the
obvious guy
yeah like i i i mean even law and orders
will give you a little like
you know who you think it is not that
guy yeah
it's like oh [ __ ] all right cool this
was like more like murder she wrote
where you're like oh
all right well tom osley did do it makes
sense
yeah he's the guest star so
herve villages doesn't show up to not
kill somebody um
yeah but but it was worth watching and
hugh grant
god bless him man like [ __ ] seems to
be having the time of his life
oh yeah i read an interview with him
this week where he was like
you don't get it i hated those [ __ ]
richard curtis movies he's like
me that's richard curtis he's like i
don't think or
sound like that that's exactly how
richard curtis thinks and talks
he's he's much more acerbic and and kind
of like
like uh shitty not like in a negative
way but just like
he pulls no [ __ ] punches man and
seemed like
he was playing a character i'm not
saying like he's a real life wife killer
in real life but it seemed like he got
to play
closer to himself and he considers
himself like
darker than what we're used to from
where we were used to from him in the
90s
he did a great job i thought she did a
great job across the board donald
sutherland was great
yeah like i just i wanted i wanted that
character to either have been
smarter because he's the dumbest killer
in the world
even though apparently he's also a
sociopath um or i wanted
nicole kidman's character i wanted grace
to
catch him like i wanted to kind of start
to be her story of how
she believes the thing to be true maybe
nobody else believes it's true
right and she and he gets off of the
case but she believes that he [ __ ]
killed her
and like it becomes a weird [ __ ]
detective thing where it's you know
husband and wife he's trying to pretend
to bring the family back together and
she's trying to prove that he killed a
girl
and like but like she's on the stand
and she just like a good
cross-examination is what ultimately
brings him down
and it's like really that's um i i will
say that the
the uh when they finally show the kill
scene
brutal yeah they were not [ __ ] around
with like
they showed us that poor woman's popped
up head a lot
yeah and then when they finally showed
him doing it too it was like
yeah like it was one thing like you know
all of it's inexcusable
but she comes at him with a weapon he
[ __ ] like
gets it away and hits her and turn
that's
one thing it's another thing if you hit
her again so [ __ ] hard she goes down
and [ __ ]
it's a completely other thing when you
lay on her or kneel on her and close her
[ __ ] eyes
and then proceed to like just obliterate
like that was [ __ ] up and i didn't see
that
coming now you know they didn't play him
that way
the whole time there was never a you
know underlining [ __ ] like darkness
or something like that
suddenly they're like hey remember the
most charming guy in the show
he did the thing right yeah like you
almost wanted to be a little history
of violence right where he was a guy who
had been this person
who put it away and he's like you know
what [ __ ] it i
maybe i did kill my sister it wasn't
about like oh
[ __ ] she accidentally got out of the
house no i did something and she died
and i put that in a box
i would have i would prefer if they they
hinted at
some of that but like you know if you're
gonna go with the obvious
no he did it like then please give us
the obvious
and he did the thing when he was a kid
too which
stands to reason that he's just this guy
totally
yeah no complaints utterly watchable
i would suggest anybody enjoy it and
watch it and stuff like that but
uh i was surprised yes if and if you
want to see what like
incredibly wealthy new york living is
like
you know like it's real estate porn of
the highest caliber everyone's like oh
look at this crazy five-bedroom
brownstone ooh look at this
house on a lake that looks like it's cut
out of the lake house with keanu reeves
oh look at these law offices look at
this stuff
it's very luxe if you ever if you
like to jerk off to images of nicole
kidman crossing city streets
this is the [ __ ] freak fest this
whole
series i'm all right we're done spoiling
it so
durka durka so yeah it's it's
uh one's mileage may vary on how
you will enjoy the end of the undoing um
i
i like the beginning of this road trip
wasn't really thrilled with where we
ended up
um let's talk about a road trip we all
took
this weekend uh some of us on
thanksgiving eve at [ __ ] 12 01.
it's here and and uh give props for
props are due
this week of course the mandalorian did
chapter what 15 13 i think
the jedi um and as suspected
as hinted at as leaked what have you
uh they did the live-action debut
of ahsoka tano and as
uh predicted or as
suspected or as leaked that's all but
confirmed
yes uh a girl from clerks too as i like
to think of her
rosario dawson uh crushed it
playing uh live-action ahsoka uh the
role had only ever been played by
ashley eckstein historically throughout
the animated series
ashley by the way created her universe
the clothing line that like was bought
by
um a hot topic and stuff so she makes
like cool nerd clothing for girls man
she's so damn impressive but in any
event she's always played the character
uh this this time in live action
playing an older version of ahsoka
um from way older from the cartoons
because somebody said like
you know in the cartoon she fights vader
at one point in
in uh was it rebels
but in clone wars like you know she was
out
before uh you know execute order 60s
or whatever the [ __ ] right because she
she didn't get killed
and then recently they did that in the
clone wars where they showed
where she was for that am i correct
right i think so who knows all this [ __ ]
let's bring in jc jc fill us in on the
cartoons um so
they so ahsoka left the jedi order at
the
spoilers everybody who hasn't watched
clone wars uh left the jedi order
and then they did a few kind of pickup
episodes with her
last february when they did the clone
wars save
last season and then in rebels
uh she is
taken by ezra through like a weird time
warp
and saved from her what we thought was
her demise
with her fight with darth vader so she
we knew she happened after the vader
fight
yeah at the end of rebels there's some
weird
warp thing through the force in this
weird
kind of thing with wolves and doors
and ezra pulls her out of that
reality or whatever it is through the
force and kind of saves her
and that's where we're kind of left with
things
um ezra uh goes off on the space whales
from star trek uh to some weird spot
with grand emerald thrawn
and ahsoka goes on a mission to find
ezra
and that's where we're left off at the
end of rebels um
that fight between ahsoka and darth
vader
in that rebels episode is one of the
finest moments
in any star wars thing anywhere
any [ __ ] time and it was brought to
us by
dave filoni back in the day and dave
filoni
not only wrote this episode with ahsoka
her live-action debut which is so
[ __ ] beautiful
he also directed it and directed it
insanely well expertly one would say
this was an episode that hearkened back
to the
origins of the star wars saga um
karasawa and uh hidden fortress uh
samurai uh fights uh
the very feudal japan kind of work duels
duels and stuff
so not only did um
dave uh uh pay tribute
to the origins of of star wars and this
is a guy who
[ __ ] there's lucas and then there's
dave filoni
like in terms of the last 20 years of
star wars he's been
one of the only people adding new [ __ ]
to canon which has become
canon and stuff um he uh
like not only did he bring ahsoka into
the
real world and get to write and direct
the episode as well
and bring up references to
uh the ex extended universe
character that was created for heir to
the of the empire
like in the books back in 1990 admiral
thrawn who also
showed up in the cartoons later on is
now apparently heading
toward live action as well so
like not only did he do all that in that
episode
he also got the episode where they
[ __ ] named baby yoda for heaven's
sake
what a huge bucket of win man and like
how kind
of john favreau to like set him up
for the [ __ ] slam dunk like that like
john favreau could have been like look
if anyone's gonna do the baby yoda gets
a name episode it's the guy who created
baby yoda
but he graciously gave it over to dave
i've i've found that like very i know
their friends and their work together
and [ __ ] but like
you know in the same way that dave was
like hey man like i you know i i i
assume
i would love to do the live-action debut
of ahsoka i'm sure
fabs would have been like well i'd love
to [ __ ] tell the world what baby
yoda's name is
unless he was playing it strategically
and he knew that the world loves baby
yoda
and you know it would take a while for
him to warm up to grosgu so he's like
you [ __ ] tell him the baby's name
yeah i don't think i don't know if
groggy is gonna stick
i feel like there's a bit of you know my
mama named clay i'm gonna call him clay
i mean his one of my favorite moments in
a star wars
thing ever now also attributable
to dave filoni is the moment when
you know he says when the the man mando
says
grogu's name out loud like first has a
question where he's like grogu
he looks at him like who goes well
reacts
and then when he does he doubles down
he's going to try this [ __ ] again he
goes
grogoo and he goes dope oh i [ __ ]
love that
like it reminded me of my dog shecky
reminded me of like harley when she was
a baby
and it was so delightful to see him
react to his name he's like yes that's
my
name all this time you've just been
talking at me now you say something that
like [ __ ]
means something to me was absolutely
magical
rosario as expected as we
campaigned for on this show uh a while
back
um and i'm not saying they took the idea
from us they took the idea from the
internet
like [ __ ] everyone's been saying
rosario for ahsoka for for a long time
now
she absolutely [ __ ] crushed it as the
older wiser version of the character
um who's you know when she has that
moment where she talks about like it
happens
it happened to the best of us where she
has that anakin moment and stuff
she got to say yoda i think the first
one
mandalorian that references flat out
yoda and says the
the name which they play his theme under
when she mentions his name they play the
yoda theme to just kind of tug at your
heartstrings a little bit very briefly
um yeah this this show continues to do
the
the most stunning fan service since
avengers
end game um over and over again
uh it just i was talking to a friend of
mine um who
works with the show and i was just like
i i love this show because it makes me
literally makes me feel like a kid when
i watch it
and this person was like imagine what it
must feel like to work on it then
i feel like a kid every damn day so uh
this i mean some people online were like
this is the best episode of the entire
run
um i don't know i ain't into qualifiers
and [ __ ] like that but i know it was an
incredible episode
um i didn't want to end yeah i was
thankful for as thick as it was
they did not bury the lead she's in like
the opening [ __ ] shots of it
and they don't [ __ ] wait to show her
the view the view of her and stuff and
before
we even get some credits they [ __ ]
you know give the full [ __ ] view of
her without a hood on and whatnot
uh it was everything one could have
hoped for when one heard the notion of
an ahsoka episode and makes one insanely
excited
for the future because if that ain't a
[ __ ] show
her going off and [ __ ] looking for
ezra and [ __ ] admiral thrawn
i don't know what is like you know
[ __ ] rush that into production based
on the reaction the internet and [ __ ]
like that
head steam roll toward the ahsoka show
as quickly as possible which i
guess they can't necessarily do because
she's lined up to do
dmz with ava duvernay over on hbo
next right but i mean good oh i was
going to say
uh rosario has a proven track record
of being the link between
spin-off shows luke cage
um iron fist
yeah uh jessica jones so she did it
already for netflix's marvel why not use
rosario in the same
fashion for disney plus is star wars you
just have
ahsoka pop in i'm on
rather watch a [ __ ] weekly show over
every week
you know i mean that that like i love
this episode
much like i love the bokeh tan episode
um my
my one issue is that i want more of it
you know
like it it feels like these are like
guest star of the week
is gonna be ahsoka tano and you
introduce this amazing character and you
you tee up this awesome story
and then we're not going to touch it
again like that's it's like come on guys
i want to be there like
let's let him team up let's [ __ ] it i
want mando and and
ahsoka for the next five episodes where
i want ahsoka and poketan together i
want
i want more of the awesome buffet they
keep serving but
the conveyor belt of joy just keeps
taking
the nummy thing away from me
what's cool about that though is you
they're
they're showing us the future
like you know like this is what
the future of star wars looks like more
and more streaming shows
with budgets of features that get to
tell
far longer stories um
set amongst the ephemera of star wars
but not
you know predicated on skywalkers or
anything like that
i you know i'm i'm content to to wait it
out like
think about it right now this is just
constant proof of concept for them
like if anyone was on and i don't know
why anyone would ever be on the fence
like if i was [ __ ] running disney
plus
if john favreau and dave filoni was like
i want to have sex with your wife i'd be
like go do it
because you guys know exactly what
you're [ __ ] doing now are you going
to use the volume
you can have the volume make a baby
please
you know if those dudes were like oh my
god you could totally do
an ahsoka show you could totally do a
[ __ ]
you know uh the uh what are they called
the [ __ ] mandolin match
they could take their hats off yeah the
the bad batch
well what was this well they're doing
bad batch they are doing bad badge
no but what's the who when she was like
where are the
wild children or something like that oh
right
it was death watch they were all part of
death watch in the cartoon
death watch um you know there's just so
many different directions
you could go in and i like this season
is like
you know of course i'm going to like it
even more i loved all last season but i
like it that they're tying it in
to the world of star wars more and more
and more
and i don't need to see [ __ ] yoda i
don't need to ever see
luke skywalker but i like i loved
when she was just like you know i've
only seen one other guy like this
[ __ ] a wise jedi master named yoda
and [ __ ]
um i saw the internet blew up going like
what about yaddle you [ __ ]
forgetting the girl on council but
i saw a lot of people quickly punch back
of that i mean number one
dave filoni writes this episode dave
valoney is
like matthew mark luke and john to
[ __ ] george lucas's god so if
he don't know nobody [ __ ] knows so
the fact that he had ahsoka say
i've only known one other person one
other creature like that
totally tracks because she met yoda in
the clone wars and [ __ ] she didn't meet
yattle and she was not in episode one or
wherever yeah
yeah dies in between episode one and two
in canon
so ahsoka comes in after episode
how did that happen i think it happens
in a comic book or a book
in there between episode one and two
which is why yaddle isn't on the
council in you know oh you god bless him
you know you're a [ __ ] character when
they kill you between movies
see somebody was like i know yoda with a
wig that was george lucas
then john fabre was like i know
baby yoda and i think we
i think we know how that went
historically yeah i mean i i just
like i i'm i'm still making my way
through clone wars and
i love the fact that clone wars can have
all of these characters in it
that just the part of this drama is this
massive tapestry
of characters that all kind of glance
off each other and and develop together
and conflict with each other and then
you get this amazing
piece at the end of it and i i loathe a
little bit the idea
that mandalorian couldn't also be
something like that
and not just the proof of concept and
all right mando's going to be this just
launching pad for other things
that seem to have the stuff you kind of
want but we're not going to keep them
with the mandalorian
like the mando's still going to just be
this guy he just walks around with his
mission i gotta take this baby somewhere
and meanwhile you're gonna have awesome
[ __ ] with ahsoka looking for thrawn
and maybe encountering luke skywalker
and then you're gonna have bokeh tan
going up against moff gideon to get her
[ __ ] dark saber back
and all this cool shit's going to happen
and then mando's like i dropped the bit
he's like the postmates guy of baby
yoda's
i'm looking for money so i can throw my
money at you because i want to watch
your show
well it's what they did with season one
right they're like here here's cara dune
hey here's
uh you know apollo creed hey here's
this cool ig-88 that's not iron
and and then at the end they brought the
band back together which
i i feel like that's what we're getting
here right
we're meeting each person and we'll get
bokeh tan and we'll get ahsoka and we'll
get that admiral ackbar dude with the
sweater in the last episode to try to
you know save the day right which is
kind of fun
it's like the avengers end game moment
where they all come through
and you're like oh they're all together
finally
yeah i mean we could do that at the end
of every season but we're going to know
exactly what they're doing
all right here's when the band gets
together again
here's where they all stand and fight
what what episode
are they on right now uh
this is episode five of this they do
eight
per year so we have three more so
there's only three more
men of the mandalorian
mundo um
dazzling episode almost doesn't matter
what happens this week
yeah i mean uh rolling back to what you
initially said
is uh dave filoni is the one who brought
john favreau into the star wars universe
and made him
a mandalorian back in season
three of the clone wars previzla was
voiced by john favreau
so this must have been payback for for
his gateway into star wars
that's why you pulled jc into the
conversation kids he knows [ __ ]
wow that's [ __ ] deep cuts well done
um i loved it more of that less of
[ __ ] everything else man it
absolutely delivered i watched it and
then instantly
[ __ ] watched it again right
afterwards man
yeah whole internet you agree too i
didn't see anybody going like [ __ ] this
no i mean there's there's your standard
internet grumbling
maybe it's less standard but you know um
rosario's had some some issues in the
past
the recent past um with lawsuits and and
and alleged transphobia which she has
cleared up
in a number of times in a number of ways
most recently in vanity fair
had a great q and a with uh with dave
and rosaria talking about it
and anthony bresnik and who conducted it
you know just did his job and was like
there's a band of this audience that has
a problem because you have these
allegations
and she addressed she's like i all these
complaints have been dismissed
not even settled out of court just
dismissed um
it's been a personal thing and this
person kind of came for me um but
anybody who knows me knows that i've
been an ally to the lgbtqia community
since the very beginning
and you know i'm not that person um so
yeah like that's that's the slight
glimmer of you know you know
pee in your porridge i suppose um but
it's
kind of minor and it seems to be at the
rallies rosario's doing exactly what she
should be
and talking about it um you know it's
it's less
weird than the the carrot dune
issues where she seems to be
not great join
parlor right yeah yeah
yeah um yeah the uh i
saw that uh rosario uh reached out you
know she couldn't say anything all this
[ __ ] time right until the moment the
episode
dropped and [ __ ] and even then she
couldn't be like i'm [ __ ] ahsoka
but um you know she had been up for a
while
and finally she was able to reach out
publicly
to ashley you know and be like i
couldn't have done this without you and
stuff
which is i'm sure something she wanted
to do
and maybe did privately like a long time
ago but like you know
they had her signed like a gazillion
[ __ ] nda so she go yeah
so now she got to a moment where she can
acknowledge that
a she's in it and like you know
ashley for doing it first and stuff like
that
um i i thought i was so [ __ ]
delighted and i was trying to think i
was like i think that's the first
cast member of mine in a star wars movie
one of my kids in a star wars i could
think of
um now i'm like oh i got a [ __ ] you
know dc
hero i got a batman i got a daredevil
because it was the same guy
i got and now i got somebody in the star
wars one
you know if i could just get muse into
harry potter [ __ ] be amazing
uh and i i appreciate that rosario at
this point is collecting
the infinity gauntlet of of uh
franchises
and we know that's [ __ ] true she told
me at the movies pop-up
out in los angeles and whatnot she was
just like i
i just want to get on star trek now
she's like me and my brother huge
[ __ ] star trek fans and [ __ ]
like i just want to get on star trek and
i was like well i know a guy that works
at star trek
and and i i you know i made a couple
calls i was like you know who would
really like to be on star trek
star trek people or zario dawson
um if if they weren't interested before
i'm sure they're gonna be way interested
when they see how [ __ ] like
oh yeah she's now like she's honestly
the new princess leia of star wars think
about it he can't really do
princess leia stories anymore unless
they're animated because carrie's gone
uh the rey stories are done
unless you know you're doing animated
who's your female centerpiece man
now they got a new one now they got one
for the next generation
that comes from you know the the lure
um been around for a while so smart
smart play i i'm telling you this is the
new disney princess is the socatana
yeah and it's it's a really interesting
princess to choose
for any number of reasons but at the
least of which is that a
she's a full-on [ __ ] jedi not like in
training not like
poorly counseled by somebody not like
i'm the force
you know positive it's i'm a [ __ ]
jedi
um and and there's such melancholy like
that's that that's what i was struck by
watching rosaria's performance is that
you can tell
just the weight that she carries of
everything she's been through
but still finds ways to pierce that veil
with like every now and again you would
catch a smile
and you get a glimmer of a memory from
humanity to the gym yeah
just like it's not all you know just
this this avalanche of misery and pain
because every now and again she's like
i'm doing the right thing and i know i'm
doing the right thing
and i can feel good about doing the
right thing and i'm like
kind of like obi-wan kind of like
obi-wan star wars
yeah you know the disney people
um you know who have been very marketing
who've been very good about like they
didn't let us know about baby yoda
before baby yoda happened and
we had to wait like [ __ ] eight to
months to a year for baby yoda products
and now they're all over the place and
stuff like that
but you know if i'm disney i'm looking
at that [ __ ] ahsoka
tano headpiece and just going like when
them parks reopen
we're gonna sell the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] games in the back of them and
whatnot oh my god
sell me some white lightsabers like
nobody's business yeah i'm telling you
if i'm them i start [ __ ] turning on
the ahsoka atm the ahsoka tm because
they can make money off of that
character man that's character that
you're right like she's a warrior
princess man she's
she's so jedi she walked away from the
[ __ ] dead eyes
a choice i got all i need from you
people
well it's also it's also a character
that
i mean we're all of the same age group
but there's a whole generation of people
who didn't grow up with
carrie fisher and princess leia they
grew up with ahsoka tano
and ashley eckstein and now as those
kids come into adulthood they get a
person of color
to be their hero which um absolutely
right
on on our show last night that we we did
two and a half hours on
last night's epi on that episode last
night
and um the people in our chat were
really excited to say
you know when i go to when i watch a
star wars red carpet it means the world
that i get to see
a brown person play my hero which i
thought was super cool
yeah yeah it's true that's something i
didn't thought about but you're
absolutely right yeah
um man oh man uh oh great all around
ex executed perfectly elevated
i dare say couldn't have gone better
like
you want to talk about [ __ ] clearing
the bar and sticking the landing jesus
they just they just like that instantly
overnight
they changed star wars history forever
with a piece of star wars history that a
lot of people didn't know about
it was wonderful to see a bunch of
people on twitter be like who is this
this character badass and have no
reference for the character whatsoever
it's like oh guess what buddy you've got
a hundred hours of content
yes you like this deep dive my friend
yeah um all right enough about the
uh the brilliant episode of the
mandalorian that made everyone so happy
this week um it's uh
i'd say i'd go so far as to say it
healed the nation you
[Laughter]
i'll say close clothes will ever get
yeah there's still some work to be done
um
yo you wanna do news i wanna do news um
but i was debating whether or not i
wanted to do the star wars bridge
to the next news item or leave the last
star wars news item for the end
let's do it for the end we'll do it for
the end all right so much star wars
fan um all right mark is a news hound
was a new sound thank god he's now just
creative cat like the rest of us and
[ __ ] like that but back in the day he
was trained in
hard news and he used to [ __ ] write
news and edit news and
eat drink and sleep and think news
until he walked away from it like the
mandalorian a man by himself
out in the galaxy i don't need news i
got my pouch a baby and i'm on my way
exactly same stuff in any event
we turned to mark to find us some news
mark
let's hear the news uh the news
news um today uh some news broke which i
found very interesting
um were you a toxic avenger fan
back in the back in there i was a toxic
avenger fan by virtue of the fact that
the toxic avenger is new jersey's
first superhero um when i was a kid
and the toxic avenger happened i
remember on abc eyewitness news
they ran a piece about what a movie
that's being shot in new jersey and then
he
talked about not just the toxic avenger
but all the trauma films
and i remember that changed my life
where i was like you can make movies in
new jersey
and i didn't turn around and do that the
next day but many years later
i would eventually go make a movie in
new jersey man troma was inspiring for a
kid that loves hollywood
to have a little piece of it in new
jersey like in these defiant rebels who
are like this is where we do our [ __ ]
thing and they make
a very specific kind of flick and stuff
i always deeply uh adored them and
respect them and [ __ ]
unlike james gunn i didn't get to work
for him and stuff i had my own thing
going on but
they they were a big factor that all
beings
in inspiring me to become what i became
that all being said
you know when i was a kid the toxic
avenger was you know what it was
just like it's it's like [ __ ]
clerks it's you know cheap and
made with passion but like you know not
made with a lot of expertise
or with a lot of budget and [ __ ] and the
fact that it holds together is an
absolute minor miracle it's an
indie film classic so
when they came to me a few years ago and
said
would you like to help us reboot the
toxic avenger
i was like oh that's interesting like oh
i hadn't even thought of that but i am
from new jersey and
i do think that like you know me making
that movie might make
sense yes let's have meetings about it
and akiva goldsman came over my house
and we talked about he's one of the
producers on it and stuff
um and talked about where the story
would go and the direction and stuff
and uh then we talked about the budget
and you know if you know anything about
the toxic avenger it costs
[ __ ] nothing you know bucko 5.
this one was not going to be the you
know price of a marvel movie by any
stretch of the imagination
but it was in a budget range that i
found myself
uncomfortable with where i was like why
would you spend that much money
rebooting the toxic adventure like you
guys remember what the toxic avenger is
right like are you sure you want to
spend this much money doing it and stuff
so i that's where i kind of parted ways
i didn't write any
drafts or anything like that um just had
a few meetings and came up with a take
but once i saw and there was a script if
i remember correctly yes that i was
going to rewrite
but once i realized that they were
interested in doing a
30 to 50 million dollar version
of the toxic avenger that's when i was
like i am not your visionary
like my vision is to do this [ __ ] as
cheaply as possible because that's what
the original one looks like but
you know there are plenty of cases out
there of people to take an original
you know inexpensive [ __ ] movie and
turn it into something else
little shop of horrors comes to mind
sheriff you came to me and said like
can you you know conceive of a [ __ ]
off-broadway musical based on this
little movie i'd be like no the only
thing to do is to make it again
in color maybe or something like that
thankfully there are people out there
that have
vision see things bigger than they are
and whatnot
i could not see past what i know
as the you know toxic avenger what i
grew up with as a toxic avenger
which is a low budget classic and the
idea of doing it for
tens of millions of dollars just like to
make no that's when i was like you need
somebody else
because i don't have that version of the
movie in my head and the script they had
if i remember correctly
there was some cool [ __ ] in it like some
good reasons
why the character became the character
and mind you
this toxic avenger has like
has legs like you know back in the day
they made like not just the movies and
there were a few but they made
cartoons yeah action figures stage play
stage play there's he's traveled he's
got some uh
you know [ __ ] some my legitimate
stuff but
i i did not again i didn't think i was
the guy
so i stepped away and then i never heard
anything about it again so i assumed
nobody was doing anything with it and it
just stopped happening
yeah no this was just an excuse for you
to tell that story next item
who is playing the toxic avenger in this
new toxic avenger that they're talking
about doing
um peter dinklage emmy winner
par excellence peter dinklage is going
to star in legendary's new toxic avenger
movie now
right then and there that that
makes the difference between me and
other filmmakers because
that i'm like wow i'd watch that and i
was literally asked to make it but i was
like i can't see how you can make it
and all they had to do was go like peter
dinklage is the toxic avenger and i'm
like i would totally [ __ ] watch that
movie
like that and you know they will wind up
making it
like with a budget and stuff and the
filmmaker they got doing it
he made a movie that was at sundance a
couple years ago that i saw and really
liked his name is making something
making yeah making blair
he he directed this movie which honestly
like the leap from the movie he made to
this movie
is pretty substantial the movie he made
at sundance was real
serious insanely well made film you know
this sounds like it's
a movie but yeah um you know and
and to your point like i i can see how
like james cameron makes the first
terminator for like four million dollars
you know low budget movie like you know
pinched every penny you know
all kinds of ingenuity to make that
thing happen and then you know for a
sequel
it's like i don't know i know exactly
what you would do with 100 million
dollars now
i know 100 how you use that money to to
finally realize every idea that i had
that i couldn't do
but you know toxic evangel is special
because of its
kind of skin flintness um and and
big part of its mythology is the fact
that it looks like that
to me it was akin to the idea of
somebody being like
we're gonna make a 50 million dollar
clerks and i'm like
why would you do that that's not part of
the charm was that it was this
homemade thing so but i think
you know the id once they said peter
dinklage is the toxic avenger i was like
oh i could totally see that so once
again it takes visionary folks
i was not visionary i will always think
of the toxic avengers
one thing from my childhood and stuff
and i'm not
like you know we we took [ __ ] masters
of the universe and and wove a brand new
[ __ ] tale
but so it's not like i can't get my head
around
taking something and making it something
new or refreshing it but
that one i never i never would have seen
this coming but now that i
they i read it i was like i could i
would totally watch that movie i bet you
that movie works
yeah i i was not interested at all until
it's peter dinklage then it's like
oh now i'm curious you said it's
more succinctly than i ever could yeah
that's breaking news that's happening
right [ __ ] now
yeah man so uh what else we got we got
you know it's similar news that we had
last week i have a feeling we're going
to get similar news going forward
in the same way that we reported every
week about some movie who had been
pushed out of
2020 into 2021 because of kovid um
we i have a feeling we'll soon be
talking with regularity about some giant
movie that was pushed from 2020 into
2021
will now get pushed onto streaming so
last week it was wonder woman 84
which is making its debut christmas day
on hbo max
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you this stage
alone for a second
while i yeah you do your thing yeah i
gotta do something that facebook doesn't
approve of jc
can mark go full screen or is it no it's
just the
uh you could i can turn you off i think
let me see if i can just turn you off
well
i don't like this i like the swamp thing
screen though it's very
green and murky and you can see me if i
if i put a little more light on me
because can you see that
yes it's like my grandmother used to
describe how she could see at age 78
she's like i just see movement
um okay what's the scoop the scoop is uh
godzilla vs kong
um another another film from the
legendary pictures folks
um looks like it'll be the latest big
franchise to head to a streamer
according to the hollywood reporter uh
netflix had made an offer
of more than 200 million dollars for the
film
um what what what
what he's back
200 million dollars they offered yes
to warner media for the rights to stream
well i mean that does sound like an
impressive figure but
what uh what do you think that movie
cost it probably cost
in that neighborhood you know maybe 150
you know because they're not like
chucking these things so it gives
premium on top a little bit of scratch
on top
a little bit of scratch on top this
transaction would be netflix is like
look you made a thing you can't do
anything with a thing
we will overpay for that thing but then
well this was warner brothers so they
were like that's tempting
but i don't know if you know this we
have our own [ __ ] streamer over here
and maybe we want to put it there is
that right that is pretty much right
um you know right now warner brothers is
you know warner bros spokesperson says
we plan to release godzilla versus king
kong theatrically next year as scheduled
but it is also potentially and
and to a certain degree probably what's
happening is that warner media will make
a deal
with legendary um for it to premiere in
hbo max
instead of instead of netflix it's a
smart deal look in a world where
[ __ ] in a world where uh wonder woman
is debuting on hbo max day and date with
some theaters and stuff
and absolutely do the same thing for
congress godzilla i'd be curious i mean
you know i'm not a
man who plays the markets mark but i'd
be curious to see
if all these moves you know like putting
wonder woman up like if it does result
in more subscribers a deluge of
subscribers
if i remember correctly disney plus had
a lot of people rushing to join when
they put up hamilton is that correct
yeah yeah i mean these are all
subscriber plays
um you know because i don't think that
that hbo max
wants to put up a sort of financial
barrier
um for people like we're not going to
charge a premium for you to watch wonder
woman we're not going to charge a
premium for you to watch
um godzilla versus confidence up there
the weight disney put a premium on the
lawn
because for them it's about getting
those subscribers in and the wonder
woman window is only a month long
you know you can only watch wonder woman
84 in hbo max
for a month that's right and then it
disappears off hbo max and then goes up
onto regular pvod where if you want to
buy it for your 15 20 bucks you can
um and then i'll still have it's
theatrical window concurrently running
um but and so i think it's literally we
just want you to
sign up for this month because we'd like
these numbers by the end of the year
um and then you can still satisfy all of
your other partners that you had before
you know you're still going to make
discs and maybe sell those you're still
going to have your itunes
you know gate front store and fandango
and any other place you'd buy movies
all of that stuff will still be in play
um and so maybe godzilla vs kang does
this
maybe black widow decides to do this but
you know it's
it's hard to tell what the the
environment is going to be like
in six months for going back to the
movies um
a vaccine will help immeasurably
you know i think build consumer
confidence to leave the house whether
that also
results in people packing movie theaters
again i don't know
that you know for me personally no i'm
not doing opening night anywhere
for another year i don't think um
so who knows who knows this feels like
it's it's better than
nothing which is currently what they're
staring down the barrel of
also i do think there's something like
these movies these massive expensive
movies like if they're on your books
like for another [ __ ] year like
you know these are costs they'd like to
write off and
move on and stuff like that so
you know in a world where in a world
where it doesn't seem like they're going
to be able to
do what they normally do with these
billion dollar franchises
like do what you can
you know yeah it's it's it's you know it
might be a bad deal but it's better than
no deal
better than sticking them on a [ __ ]
shelf and going like one day
yeah you know and stop i mean also think
about it
all the other streamers they're still
producing entertainment and [ __ ] like
that
it's like you know you're the longer you
sit your movie on the shelf going like
no no
[ __ ] as soon as this quarantine's
done you're gonna be out of step
[ __ ] shit's gonna be you know [ __ ]
late or you know stale a little bit
or whatever i mean something like wonder
woman in 84 can never go [ __ ] stale
because it's period piece right
but you know if i'm them i'm scared like
is there some other [ __ ]
movie that does something we do in it
and [ __ ] like that
you know and then there's just the you
were counting on making that money back
to help you make more of the next stuff
and if you don't have the money coming
in it's like oh
we spent 500 million dollars making
movies last year and we made
zero money back how do we afford the
next string of movies
that is already on the runway okay we
gotta have something coming in
and uh so yeah hopefully that will that
will resolve in a way that a lets us see
it earlier and b lets
everybody make a little bit of money and
keep live long enough to fight another
day
i uh i would totally watch that movie
particularly at home uh i enjoyed uh
kang island skull islands that one's fun
delightful movie um all right what else
we got
um we i think we spoke about the nevers
um a while back when it was first
announced josh sweden's sweden hbo show
indeed his big sort of female victorian
superhero
um jimmy jam
the series is described as an epic
science fiction drama about a gang of
victorian women
who find themselves with unusual
abilities relentless enemies and a
mission that might change the world
i know nobody knows much more than that
like based on a
previous thing or just right out of his
head
you know and this was his sort of
long-awaited return to television
um after after he did dollhouse and
angel and firefly and you know kind of
you know got beaten up by fox a little
bit
um and then went off to make movies and
made the avengers and cabin in the woods
and age of ultron then got beaten up by
life a little bit
and got beaten up by life a little bit
and so this was supposed to be his
triumphant return to the small screen
where he made his his uh his name and
fortune
um and it seems as if he has departed
this show that he created and nursed
from uh from a wee idea
into into fruition where they they
finished production
on a first season and was picked up for
a second um
he's done a full season the show he's
done a full season the show
um and the the statement from hbo was we
have parted ways with joss whedon we
remain excited about the future of the
nevers and look forward to its premiere
in the summer of 2021.
um according to john those lines can you
can you see anything there well let me
let me read you josh's statement because
josh also offered
a statement um this year of
unprecedented challenges has impacted my
life and perspective in ways i never
could have imagined
and while developing and producing the
numbers has been a joyful experience i
realized that the level of commitment
required moving forward
combined with the physical challenges of
making such a huge show during a global
pandemic
is more than i can handle without the
work beginning to suffer
i'm genuinely exhausted and i'm stepping
back to marshall my energy towards my
own life
which is also at the brink of excited
change i'm deeply proud of the work we
have done i'm grateful to my cast and
collaborators and to hbo for the
opportunity to shape yet another strange
world
um so you know it it
again i i have never heard
of a person of their own volition
stepping away from a thing they've given
so much time to create
um it it rarely if ever happens and i've
never heard of it happening before
did he step away from the avengers um
well his story similarly was he was
exhausted
from making um for making age of ultron
um but there was other stuff happening
in his life at that time
um he was going through a very public um
and not entirely amicable split with his
now ex-wife
um and uh and currently he is
undergoing investigation um by warner
brothers
um which was prompted by ray fisher's
allegations of
justice league reshoots yeah um so it
has anything to do with that i bet you
does
ray fisher absolutely believes it does
um it's unclear whether that is
the truth or or or you know
wish fulfillment on ray fisher's part
but could it be as simple as a guy who's
like i'm really sleepy
it it could be it would be the first
time in history of ever that that has
actually happened
um but it could be like man this is just
too much for me
i can't do this anymore so then you know
we're not a hard news show so we can do
this sort of thing and we [ __ ]
speculate on things all the time
if it is not a choice there it's
somebody asking him to go
it's i i you know i think it might be
that
you know i think it might be you know
again
based on nothing but just looking at the
cards that are on the table
um and not knowing what anybody else has
in the hole
um that warner brothers has asked him to
leave and
he has agreed to do so probably
you know begrudgingly probably he you
know and i'm sure they're paying him to
get out of his contracts for doing so
what would be why wouldn't they want him
you think
i mean the only thing that i can think
of is that perhaps this investigation
has actually uncovered things
that might be actionable and this is the
action that they're taking
um you know it it seems a little similar
if only in timing to the johnny depp
being asked to resign from you know
fantastic beasts
was that that was a case of him you know
losing his court case and so they were
like
yeah like we don't want to have to deal
with this as you know
oh it's it's that guy spousal abuser
johnny depp
in fantastic beasts they don't want
those headlines
this might just be we found some things
about josh that we're not pleased about
um and then here's my my only
question then in a world where
ray has been very vocal about
things that you know impropriety is
whatever
uh on the set of the justice league
reshoots
and talking not letting it you know
die down anytime soon like
if you were warner bros and that was the
reason you were letting the guy go
wouldn't you want to be like hey
everybody
you know remember we were asked to do
this do due diligence and we did and
this was the result
like would you really be like all right
quietly go and make up a story
you know what i'm saying yeah i mean
maybe maybe the condition of this
is is that maybe joss was like you know
what
we're not going to say what the actual
reasons are whatever they might be
i will release a statement saying that
i'm doing this in my own volition
if you agree to release a statement just
saying that you've that
i've agreed to leave the show um you
know we play this very
you know as as we said when we first
talked about the ray fisher stuff
everything is usually very palatable and
very like creative differences
like we just didn't see eye to eye and
we're going a different way and
but we wish him well we're really proud
of the work that he did we can't wait to
release the show
that's hollywood derragur for this kind
of creative breakup
and it's very often negotiated by
publicists and it's very often
you know crazy angry and bitter behind
the scenes but on the surface
it's everybody's just one big happy
family jc
what is anyone is saying in the chat
about this do people have theories of
their own and stuff and mind you right
now kids this is just
might as well be an episode of the
[ __ ] crown this ain't reality
uh we're talking about people with real
names in real situations but now we're
just
off the grid speculating on what this
might be and stuff yeah so we're eating
tea leaves and we have no degree in tea
leaf reading
not at all and nor do we know any of the
parties involved and stuff but this is
just fans going why
why uh jc what are they saying in chat
if anything
uh they're bringing up uh the johnny
depp's stuff
they're saying uh uh some
it's split kind of 50 50 on it
kind of the pro whedon anti-whedon
uh what they're talking about
he seems like just didn't care about
justice league reshoots
um there's a lot of talk about amber
heard
okay because she's involved now
i think they're they're comparing the
whedon thing to
um to what happened with johnny depp on
fantastic beasts so they're like if
[ __ ]
if whedon's gone she they better
send her next or something like that
yeah well that's there is now a petition
that's like a million and a half
signatures strong
to recast amber heard for aquaman two
um given that million and a half a
million and a half signatures on this
petition
um i think in in good part they're
johnny depp fans
who are like i think yeah yeah i think
who are like if if
if my boy's gotta give away his
franchise and he's involved with this
and she too is just as involved as he is
and so we believe that if his name isn't
good enough to be on this movie then why
is her name good enough to be on that
movie
you should take her name off too does
that change anybody's mind one iota of
signatures um i i don't
think so but this is also warner
brothers do you really care
but then on the other hand it's like you
know not with all due respect to amber
hurt it's like
you know they change [ __ ] actors all
the time
so you put somebody else in that
halloween wig and you got a new mirror
yeah i mean i'm sure that that you know
it would be easy to say
like who gives a million and a half
signatures on a petition who cares
and zack snyder is shooting 70 million
dollars worth of reshoots
for his justice league version
man i'm saying that's like you know
there's some maybe
maybe that's enough to actually yeah
interesting all right what else we got
um and our last news
item of the day uh isn't that the last
of the news
this is it the last of the news and this
is is this about black widow
no i saw a story today about
uh what's her name florence pew
the actress she's playing uh
what's her character's name ivano or
elana elena
the new black widow yes okay
yeah she gonna pop up on both hawkeye
and
uh another [ __ ] show they said falcon
winter soldier or loki falcon winter
soldier
thank you uh not one division but yes
those two shows now
we have not seen black widow yet correct
but based on this information
spoilers can be inferred no
like there will be no moment where i'm
like oh my god they're gonna kill this
girl because apparently
she's showing up to work in two other
marvel series yeah um
i before those happen they got to show
us that black widow movie right
you would you would think but
then again you know i suppose she also
works
there's a world in which that character
just showing up out of context
isn't the worst thing in the world you
know you know and and
and because also none of those other
characters in in falcon winter soldier
um and uh and what you may call it
hawkeye
okay has would not have met her i don't
think you might know who she is
i've interacted with her previously that
we know unless there's a scene in black
widow but it doesn't seem like it
right you know i mean black widow's
definitely not meeting [ __ ] falcon or
winter soldier because that's a
that's a movie in the past not in the in
the future
it's going to be exciting either way i
like you know it's nice that they're
bringing
movie characters into their [ __ ]
shows and stuff like that
um but it does make me you know anxious
for
black widow because now i want to know
that story her story
start bringing her in i just want some
more marvel stuff it's been a while
it's been a while it really has hasn't
it what end game was
no um peter spider-man yeah far from
home
home that was the last yeah last july
i need my fix man yeah baby put it right
there
all right what is the last story of the
night the last story of the night
um is the one that i debating pairing
pairing with a mandalorian because it's
a star wars story
it is our word now what's that uh you
know
it's a a long time ago in a galaxy far
far away
um it's gripping
um david prowse the actor who played
darth vader
in the first star wars trilogy died of
complications from coveted 19.
what he died of covid he did
complications from it
um he passed away on saturday but at the
time the cause of death wasn't specified
but his daughter has clarified
that it was kovid he was suffering from
alzheimer's and had been hospitalized
for the last two weeks of his life with
cobit
i'd known about the alzheimer's
somewhere along the line i'd heard that
and stuff
um so sad but uh a long life how old 85
85. um sad that it you know [ __ ]
covid claims somebody else um anybody
let alone
a guy was a big part of our childhood i
was
uh moved by this even though i never met
the man
because uh david prowse was one of the
first names i learned
as a young fan of anything as a young
pop culturalist um i knew
that the guy inside darth vader's
suit and mask was named david prowse
just like i knew that the guy who did
his voice
was named james earl jones and stuff so
that is
a rockstar name to me just like peter
mayhew
anthony daniels kenny baker these are
rock star names from my childhood
because
you know i knew these actors names
even though you never really saw their
faces it's one thing to know you know
who harrison ford is luke skywalker
carrie fisher
we're seeing them in the movie i knew
the identity of the people behind the
men behind the mask as they used to call
them when they went on tour
so prows was a name that i knew
from childhood from age seven and now 43
years later
when i heard somebody say david prowse
passed away i was
sad man i mean like that's big part of
my childhood gone away but at the same
time
what an adventurous life this guy led
well
and look at all the [ __ ] he got to do
not just of course
um this movie but like somebody tweeted
something that he was in where i was
like get the [ __ ] out of here that was
him
yeah clockwork orange awkward yeah and
he played uh
he played the caretaker of the woman who
gets assaulted by the drugs
i believe and like that opening salvo um
you know and he was a [ __ ]
weightlifting champion
and a thing that i remember discovering
only because i read about it it's not
like i on
i wasn't doing the skull duggery to dig
out this fact but
he um he was instrumental in helping to
teach
christopher reeve how to train to be
superman
i remember vaguely hearing something
about that darth vader training [ __ ]
superman
yeah because i was a weightlifter i was
a weightlifter well my entire life was
spent just like bulking up and getting
my body in shape and and christopher
reeve had to go
from like this to kind of scrawny 170
pound
you know 6-2 actor to put on 40 pounds
of muscle
and so they asked me if i would work
with him and i did because he was a
lovely man
and they were making that movie like
while star wars was
coming out like so before david prowse
was like a household name
in the movie community world but uh how
charming
how sweet huge bucket of wind man and
the guy without whom created
the gigantic stature of uh
darth vader himself um james earl jones
though also a tall guy probably could
have pulled it off
he probably couldn't probably could have
but probably very happy that he didn't
have to [ __ ] wear that outfit
you mean i still get paid i have to say
you want me to walk up to a mic
and [ __ ] like just own the
performance
i saw tasty pop in and jc knows a lot
about star wars so he probably has some
david brown's sentiment to say
i was just going to shout out the chat
room that's talking about the superman
effect that mark
uh called out which i thought was really
cool
what was the what were the other movies
that he was in
um chat was saying clockwork orange
and uh something something frankie
they played frankenstein's monster like
two with frankenstein in one of the
movies
let's see uh hammer horror films is what
people are saying
so before star wars he was in a lot of
hammer horror films
wow another one gone man yeah
yeah so a picture that somebody online
or i'm sure multiple people have tweaked
but it was one of those um you know
publicity stills
from the very first like behind the
scenes during the press campaign for
star wars
and you know it was a picture of
everybody you know it was it was you
know harrison and carrie and
and and mark and david and kenny and
anthony and
and uh and alec and then they had sort
of blued out
all the people who have now turned to
force ghosts because they've left us
ah that's great yeah and so it's just
you know harrison
mark and anthony romain and everybody
else
has has since passed on i was like oh
that's sweet that's weird to think about
but like you know how sometimes you
watch
old black and white movies and you're
like all these people are dead now
there is a time one day [ __ ] you know
probably 20 30 years from now when that
will be
true of probably less than that well
that will be true of star wars where
nobody will be left is that right
yeah yeah in our lifetime we will have
lost the entire
original trilogy cast oh i don't want to
live in that [ __ ] world
walter flanagan would always say like i
just want to live long enough to the
aliens land and when they land
that's when i want to die because i
don't want to know if they're here for
good or [ __ ] bad
i just want to live until the last star
wars person
has lived take me out
worst of all possible worlds with no
more star wars folks in it
that's all the news that's all the news
my friend look at that give it up for
mark he gave you the news ladies and
gentlemen he went out there and found
the [ __ ] news
you're staying in your house because of
[ __ ] colvin he's out there getting
the news
he's a first responder he's uh what do
they call him a essential worker
[Laughter]
for nobody you see we must have
people must want to know things right
all right i'm not going to bury the lead
the
talk in the chat all night has been who
do you guys want to see
play grand emerald thrawn in the
mandalorian
so that's going to be my question of our
q a
portion of the show ladies and gentlemen
question number one is a dues
is a doozy i it's so weird that i had
not prepared an answer for this i should
have thought of this
the moment she said the character's name
my head should be
working around who would play that
character
um so now
let's see well mads mickelson's already
been in a [ __ ] star wars movie he
seemed like
good pick for admiral yeah can't have
him again
can't have him again it ain't tom hanks
i'll tell you that
america's dad that's grand admiral
thrawn
um i mean is it is it uh
too far no i think i think i'm here
um was magneto's name young magneto
oh um michael fassbender
there's my pick michael j thrawn oh come
on man
like he's got that he can give him a
[ __ ] bit of a german accent and [ __ ]
he comes across with that magneto
malevolence and [ __ ]
he's a good i pick him or my alternate
sam rockwell
sam rockwell can make anything work man
he could make a blue
uh what do they call what's his race
called not cis but
like uh it's shifts
c-h-i-s-s he can totally [ __ ]
play a chess man
um or my third choice yes
idris elba for everything on board i can
absolutely [ __ ] rock that and look
characters blue so it could be [ __ ]
anybody at that point just as very much
watchmen you know it's
you could you could totally go diverse
with it as well
um jc i will i will ask you a question
because i don't have an answer
and you seem to be the man um do the
chiss
age um like normally would he be
older by the time we're catching up with
him or are we looking at like a just
mid-40s dude i think we're looking at
like uh
yeah like mid-40s dude i don't think
they
they age the same way
or at least they've never been portrayed
as uh
like old men looking okay
all right my first choice is um mark
strong
who played um sinestro in the the
green lantern movie and was the uh the
armorer
in uh in the kingsman movies um
but he's just got such a good look
shazam he played uh
savannah he's got such an amazing voice
and i feel like a voice is a big part of
that
um and turning to a person who has
experience playing uh blue aliens
um lee pace i think would be great
nice and he knows what it's like to be
in the blue
it's true he's worn the blue before um
all right what do you think jc you got
to pick uh i'll share what the chat is
saying
which is a lot of love for jeremy irons
i think that's the overwhelming um you
know
[ __ ] that's a genius call especially
if you were doing an older thrawn
because basically you'd be doing klaus
von bulows
that's and then a lot of love for uh
zach zachary quinto quinto
spock young spock is thrown
nah
i think the idea is is thrawn is
tactical
and uh calculated kind of like
how quintos played spock
yeah but to be fair like that's just the
screen direction
you know it's like you [ __ ] you could
cast
you know uh
jelly or white hey
hey man plan calculating and [ __ ] the
guy who gave you oracle is going to give
you an admiral thrawn
so it's not like you know zach zachary
quinto owns the has the [ __ ] lockdown
on like oh i could do calculating
like i can be cold yeah jeremy irons is
a [ __ ] great pull particularly if
you're doing a guy who is older and
stuff like that
yeah then you get that mom do [ __ ] um
ozymandias as well
and then you get that feeling that
ahsoka's been chasing him for his entire
life
and now she finally finds him at the end
of his days and he's just
tired
you have no idea
[Music]
i'll say my pick is uh the same as matt
uh
matt in chat which is peter sarafinowicz
who was also the voice of darth maul in
episode 1.
he's also in uh the hebrew who's the
tick
right now he's the tick isn't he uh and
he was
he was most recently yeah he was also in
nova corps
in guardians i believe that's right he's
the one who's like
what's a bunch of [ __ ] or whatever
he's also in uh sean of the dead edgar
wright's movie
he's the the flatmate who gets [ __ ]
bit right off the top that's how they
figure out that the world's
been zombified great choice great
choices all around
uh indeed all right that was question
number one question number two
jc is what all right we're gonna keep it
star wars
uh zachary habib wants to know
if there are no jedi left but you could
pluck
any character from any other universe
to raise and train grogu who
would you pick who would be grosgu
surrogate dad if the mandalorian
could not do it
non-star wars mr miyagi
he's he was a great teacher and you know
he's got
age on his side i mean look if you're
talking about mr miyagi from karate kid
i bet you he was about 50 in that movie
like he was white-haired
and we saw it as children so we always
think of him as like oh he was in his
80s but i guarantee you if you look at
[ __ ]
what's his name pat morita you look at
his imdb
i bet you he was like 50ish when he made
[ __ ] crowded kid
so if he was 50 mr miyagi was 50 and
[ __ ] baby yoda or
grogu is uh 50. that's a good match
it's nice it's like it's like old dogs
or like bucket list
yes yes um
go ahead you go i was gonna i was gonna
go um
and i could not remember their
characters names for the life of me but
i just feel like three men and a baby
yoda
um is kind of perfect so you got your
ted danson's and your gutenberg's
and your celix and your celex tom's like
that stash can absolutely raise a child
it's all [ __ ] goot when you got the
gutenberg
on that that's good um
what about uh
what was his name pie may from [ __ ]
he'd be a harshman not father of the
year
by a man
also and just as let me see hold on um
who could be a good teacher because
those are like you know
um like somebody who teaches them the
ways of something
is this just to replace mando if like
mando was gone replace
man anybody from outside star wars
replace mando with anybody outside star
wars is that it
yeah who would make a good dad to uh to
little grogu
tom hanks america's dead
the universe is that mark don't limit it
to america's that's how you're putting
his dad could you imagine the adventures
of tom hanks and grogu
hooch all over again who didn't [ __ ]
love turner hooch except this time
the dog don't die and that dog is baby
yoda
wait did the dog die and
[Laughter]
well it's a movie about a dog nine times
out of ten the dog ain't making it to
closing credits
that's a great movie um all right who do
you think i i i go uh i don't go dead i
go mom
i go ellen ripley from aliens oh
drop do me a favor you got a microphone
i'll wait go grab one and then you drop
it
okay hold on this is this is my one
microphone
nice nice here it is
um you save jc's ears
that is a great [ __ ] call man ellen
ripley get away from him you
[ __ ] they only come at night
mostly fantastic [ __ ] answer um all
right
that's a great question yielded some
great response jc you got an answer
uh chat liked alfred like batman's
alfred um
master splinter and uh
oh splinter is adorable uh willow
i mean he's used to carrying a baby
around
excellent point god you just put willow
into the prison for me of like
that was a bit lone wolf and cub wasn't
it that was a bit
i have this baby yeah yeah that's
i hadn't thought of it before like that
something mustache
you just want to watch the world better
those are good
yeah which alfred are we talking about
[ __ ] michael k
alfred [ __ ] jeremy irons alfred
[ __ ] michael go alfred or
alan napier is that his name alfred the
tall ass alfred from battle yeah
d.o.g albert um or
animated alfred from zembalus
he was pretty damn good um
or gotham's alfred what's his name
her chomper or for
you know he raised a boy in that show
but that's more
and then went on to be a vigilante so
maybe you don't want [ __ ] baby odor
with him
or andy circus alfred um don't give him
the jorel
he seemed like a shitty dad yeah just
gonna put him in another ship and send
him away it's like dude you could have
built the ship for three
no lara yes baby yoda's got his own
[ __ ] ship anyway
um i'll tell you who i'd give baby yoda
to in real life jason muse best father
i've ever seen
that would be one amazing [ __ ] i
don't know if he'd be getting any good
at jedi [ __ ] but he
eat a happy childhood lot of legos yes
the legos are in the air again damn it
jordan um
all right that's question two jc do we
have a
uh trifecta of star wars questions or
yeah let's
let's keep it all star wars tonight uh
with question three i will say i don't
know if you
notice this is off subject but somebody
in the chat said that jay and silent bob
get a little shout out in ready player 2
which just came out this week i did not
read the book yet but i did see that
somebody tweeted that uh
the time is referenced and the how the
character knows
the time is based on jane sampaps strike
back
so they have to put you guys in the next
movie right
isn't that what that means well to be
fair
ernie referenced me in in the first
movie and there was
spielberg didn't feel the need to
so there's a world where you know if
they make a ready player too that
we don't get referenced in it either but
i was just happy to be referenced in
in both books it's very [ __ ] uh
incredibly sweet tribute by a very cool
guy
um okay read it have you read it i
bought it
but i have not read it i actually bought
the hardcover
book i came amazon lost it so it came
yesterday but it's it's next on the list
um all right last last star wars
question this one's kind of a doozy
uh this is from uh prim arch
wants to know it's the 2070s and a new
hope has just entered public domain
you are asked your opinion on how to
retell star wars
but the rest of the star wars movies
have not entered public domain
so what uh what
how do you tell it different um
to to create a new story
because you can't touch empire and jedi
and everything that's come after
so you have you can redo a new hope
but you have to kind of retell a new
hope different enough
um
because the rest of you but do i have to
tell it different
because you know it's not like star wars
didn't
predict empire or
return of the jedi or anything like that
like that's a standalone story
i feel like i could get away without
changing anything look
remember i told you a story about
[ __ ] uh
adventure where i was like i just make
the same [ __ ] movie
same thing here i'm the worst guy to ask
because i'd be like okay number one i'm
alive in 2070 what a miracle
number two i somehow [ __ ] get the
chance to remake star wars i'm doing it
shot for shot i'm doing the gus von sant
on psycho my friend
if it worked once it'll work a hundred
years later
uh yeah i don't i don't do too much of
it i mean
here's the upshot you know full well
that empire and
jedi will be following into the public
domain in short order so you don't have
to tie up those
those threads quite as as neatly
as they do on the first one um if it's
me
i think you do like two things you you
you shave some of the opening stuff off
because i don't need to see droids walk
through the sand that much
i kind of want to meet luke skywalker a
little bit earlier in the movie than you
meet him now
um so maybe just take a look at the
front end
everything else is on rails and you
don't need to do too much to to that
stuff at all
right um and and i i never once
i'm going to have leia kiss luke in any
way at
all um because you know what
we know enough now to know that they're
brothers
you can you can include bigs you know
and [ __ ] if you wanted to uh but
mostly of course if we're doing in 2070
uh you're diversifying maybe ain't going
to be quite as
pale right yeah just all the bad guys
are black now
we'll have fixed that problem by 2070
right it's totally cool
what is what if luke when han goes hey
you're pretty good in a fight we could
use you what if luke
like looks over at the x-wing and then
looks at the money in falcon
then looks at han's giant pile of money
and was like
yeah i am good in a fight aren't i
let's go han and then you just get the
adventures
intergalactic adventures of han and luke
and chewbacca
like hopping from cantina to cantina
drinking and shooting doritos it ain't
star wars anymore but i'm [ __ ] in you
just sold me a ticket
like and in you know in this timeline
the death star just gets destroyed by
the rebels
it was just without luke they didn't
need them it's like they don't
it's right or the rebellion just
disappears and it's just these two guys
just on a lark while the rebellion burns
and ashes behind them
it's like i didn't know that lady i
don't care that much about this
you know who can make money during the
falling of an empire a couple of guys
like us
good with a blaster technically aren't
we just talking about solo
pretty much like it was man he was like
i ain't fighting in no [ __ ] war and
then he went off and
worked at the double [ __ ] yeah and also
it's it's super gay
because then it's just luke and han just
riding around in a ship that has one
testicle hanging out the side
um going from bar to bar
they manscape oh do they ever where's
the manscape
of course they do and you know who
really manscapes in the 2070 version of
star wars
chewy you don't have all that hair yes
he's going to get right in there he's
going to give a landing strip
man little virgin smoothie action luke
is going to put on the blast shield
and he's just going to do anything
you've ever seen before in these movies
he's like pretty good against remotes is
one thing kid good against a living is
another
now put on that blast shield and shave
that wookie okay
let that wookie win and every wookie
wins
when you go to manscaped.com ladies and
gentlemen don't forget to enter the code
fatman20 does your wookie need more
nookie
manscaping yeah get some of that
ball cream and stick it on them some
toner
tighten those nuts
we hit our question three we gave you a
bunch of news
we gushed about the mandalorian
you're up to date kids time to go
you don't have to go home but you have
to get the [ __ ] off out of here
um thank you to jc for making the time
making the stream and getting us into
your
into your faces and to your ear [ __ ]
so you can listen to us
uh delight you with tales of the culture
of pop
ladies and gentlemen uh if you're
in uh the minnesota area movies pop-up
is coming there december 12th
to the uh 22nd and there's only a few
slots left so go to moviespopup.com
if you're up in canada in the toronto
area movies is available through skip
the dishes they'll deliver it right to
your [ __ ] house
go to skip the dishes man and order some
movies right now
um you got anything plugged my friend i
do not at all um just [ __ ]
escape your mans go get some movies
be good to yourselves everybody love
each other you ain't wrong ladies and
gentlemen there is no show
without the guy who's not wrong who's
down there
here's the story of a man named marky
how come i can't do this i don't know
this guy right down there
that make no it's this one that guy
there it is
there it is boy that took me a while
that dude give it up for mr mark bernard
and ladies and gentlemen thank you
everybody
and uh and also thank you kevin for your
lovely words on my birthday
and for that lovely gift you sent over
adorbs i know i got
yeah thank you
um there it is that is fat man
beyond for this week i'm kevin smith i'm
mark bernard
tune in next week same fat time same fat
channel smog
well actually tune in aren't we doing
this on saturday saturday the 5th of
december
so come back this monday come back on
saturday boy i hope some [ __ ] happens
went in on saturday ladies and gentlemen
same fat time same fat channels
podcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith for the good of
all
cree ladies and gentlemen peace love and
soul
you